c'est la fin d'une longue cavale Matteo
Messina denaro le fugitif le plus
recherché d'Italie a été arrêté ce matin
dans une clinique médicale de Palerme où
il recevait des traitements pour un
cancer dernier chef présumé de la mafia
sicilienne il avait réussi à échapper à
la police pendant 3 décennies
c'est un grand jour pour l'Italie qui
paie enfin ses dettes assez martyrs
victimes de la mafia dit le procureur en
chef du pays
la première ministre italienne nous
pouvons montrer nos enfants qu'on peut
battre la mafia
mélonie est ensuite allé se recueillir
au mémorial en l'honneur du juge
anti-mafia Giovanni Falconet assassiné
par des Naro en 92 c'est notamment pour
ce meurtre ainsi que pour des attentats
à la bombe à Florence et à Rome que
Messina denaro avait été condamné en son
absence à la prison à vie en 93 il était
en fuite depuis
l'Italie à terre est enfin fini 17
habitants de Palerme
l'arrestation de denaro est symbolique
en Italie c'était le dernier
para-etactivement recherché après
plusieurs arrestations spectaculaires
depuis les années 90
la question qui se pose maintenant c'est
va-t-il ou non coopérer avec la justice
se demande ce professeur de droit
italien
car les experts croient que des Naro
affaiblis par la maladie aurait pu être
livré par des proches il pourrait
décider de briser à son tour l'omerta
rendez-vous allant les secrets de
l'organisation clandestine et en livrant
ses complices ici lise Villeneuve
Radio-Canada MONT